[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
خلال هذه الايام وان طالع من صلاه المغرب
اتجاه جهه الغرب ستشاهد جرم سماوي جميل
ولافت هذا الجرم سماوي يسمى بكوكب الزهره
والزهره ثالث المعجرم سماوي بعد الشمس
والقمر والعرب اسموه بالزهره لانه يزهو
بجماله والعامه يسمونه العشاء لانه يظهر
في وقت العشاء ويسمى ايضا بالكوكب الدري
لانه كدره بجماله وضيائه جاءت معلمتي في
غيرها بالغسق كانها الكوكب الذري في
الافقي فقلت نورتني خير زائرتي اما خشيتي
من الحراس في الطرق فجاوبتني ودمع العين
يسبقها من يركب البحر لا يخشى
من الغرق
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
واهم الاجرام السماويه عند شعوب الارض
قاطبه الشمس القمر الزهره الشعره فشعوب
البدائيه عبدت الشمس وعبدت القمر والشعوب
التاليه لها عبده الزهره والعرب عبدو
الاسلامي ابطل عليهم هذا بقوله وانه هو رب
شعره ومن الجميل اننا خلال هذه الايام
سنشاهد زحل والزهره والمشتري والشعره بشكل
لامع فوجدته تقبيل السيوف لانها لمعه
كبارها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]